revenir sur cette cérémonie d'hommage à
samuel pâtit une cérémonie avec des
témoignages poignants avec le discours
du président nous sommes avec nos
invités alexis poulain éditorialistes
kevin bossuet professeur d'histoire en
seine saint denis est avec nous
également jean-pierre colombiès porte
parole de l'association de police de
l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants
messieurs avant de vous entendre je
propose d'écouter emmanuel macron à
lorsqu'il a tenu à rappeler son soutien
au corps enseignant synonyme de devoir
républicain on l'écouté puis on réagit
ensuite nous redonnerons aux professeurs
le pouvoir de faire des républicains la
place et l'autorité qui leur reviennent
nous les formerons les considérons comme
il se doit de les soutiendrons nous les
protégerons autant qu'il le faudra dans
l'école comme hors de l'école nous
aimerons la science et ses controverses
comme vous nous cultiverons la tolérance
comme vous nous chercherons à comprendre
sans relâche et à comprendre encore
davantage cela qu'on voudrait éloigné de
nous
ce combat pour la liberté et pour la
raison donc vous êtes désormais le
visage parce que nous vous le devons
parce que
nous nous le devons parce qu'en france
professeur les lumières ne s'éteignent
jamais vive la république
vive la france kevin bosse fait le
professeur d'histoire que vous êtes
comment est ce que vous avez reçu ces
mots du président nous vous formerons
nous vous soutiendrons nous vous
protégerons nous vous donnerons le
pouvoir de faire des républicains
comment vous réagissez à ces mode
emmanuel macron bah écoutez c'est un
très beau discours sauf qu'il faudrait
que derrière le discours il ya des
salles je vous dire concrètement nous
nous avons de grandes difficultés sur
certains territoires à faire passer une
partie du programme de la république il
ya un sondage qui est sorti récemment
qui était réalisé par l'ifop qui dit
qu'il ya notamment 40% des professeurs
qui s'autocensurent dans leur salle de
classe et on est à 50 % dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire donc que compte
faire concrètement emmanuel macron pour
qu'on puisse enseigner
concrètement ce que l'on doit enseigner
sur certaines parties du territoire il
est très compliqué d'aborder certains
sujets le professeur d'histoire
géographie ne peut plus abordé la choix
ne peut plus abordé la naissance
judaïsme ne peut plus abordé le conflit
israélo palestinien ou encore la place
de l'église au moyen-âge chance d'avoir
dans sa salle de classe des
contestations
le professeur de sciences et vie de la
terre ne peut plus abordés l'origine du
monde tous ne peut plus abordés
l'éducation à la sexualité sans devoir
ses références au coran d'ailleurs il ya
un rapport qui est sorti en 2002 qui
avait dit clairement dit qu'il y avait
une théologie nation de l'enseignement
en certains endroits parce qu'on est
obligés obligatoirement de justifier les
savoir que l'on transmet par rapport au
coran donc qu'est ce qu'il compte faire
là dessus j'ai entendu la députée les
républicains ni gêne var qui veut créer
notamment un délit d' entrave à la
liberté d'enseignement que pense
emmanuel macron sur ce sujet et de
manière plus générale
moi en tant que professeur et mes
collègues on a eu tendance quand même
au cours de ces derniers mois d'être
véritablement méprise et il ya eu cette
réforme des retraites par exemple qu'ils
étaient tous qui a été pour nous
véritablement un coup de poignard on n'a
pas compris ce que emmanuel macron avait
contre nous il ya aussi nos salaires qui
sont strictement pas il
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas normal
donc si on veut redonner de l'autorité
au professeur si on veut faire en sorte
que les professeurs puisse incarner de
nouveau la république il faut que ces
professeurs soient respectés il faut que
ces professeurs soient honorés par la
nation à travers un salaire digne
donc voilà que compte faire emmanuel
macron concrètement parce que ce qui est
en train de se passer dans certaines
classes sur certains territoires
français et excessivement grave donc moi
j'en ai marre énoncé dénoncé dénoncé
maintenant de l'action c'est ce qu'on
attend parce qu'on ne peut plus attendre
la montée de l'islamisme est telle que
si on attend encore encore un peu il
sera trop tard
alexis plan pour former pour soutenir
pour protéger nos professeurs nos
enseignants aujourd'hui selon vous
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait mettre en place
en urgence en urgence c'est bien tout le
problème c'est incroyable de se rendre
compte de la faillite en fait de tout le
système républicain étatiques alors que
l'éducation nationale c'était le joyau
de la république sociale tout le
discours d' emmanuel macron est au futur
sur ce qu'il faudrait faire pour aider
les professeurs parce qu'ils ont
totalement lâchement étaient laissés de
côté donc en urgence rien
malheureusement pas parce que il va
falloir d'abord peut-être protéger les
professeurs les abords des écoles des
lycées des collèges et puis ensuite il
va falloir faire sortir la politique les
parents de l'école et que l'école soit
un sanctuaire républicain de la
connaissance du débat de la liberté
d'expression et que ce sens soit fini d
regardé comment fonctionnait
ces associations islamistes la moindre
porte entrouverte était le sujet pour
entrer et empêcher le débat empêcher est
imposée si possible une pensée unique ou
une censure l'école elle doit être
absence de l'absence de censure sur dans
le cadre des lois mais elle est le lieu
du débat elle est le lieu où les futurs
citoyens vont apprendre à être libre et
pas à prendre à des petites machines du
capital donc c'est important que les
professeurs et les moyens de
de faire cours correctement qu'il soit
effectivement payés correctement
regardez les salaires des professeurs
dans le les pays voisins européens qui
n'ont rien à voir avec encore une fois
les salaires en france mais c'est le
même problème pour les policiers pour
les infirmières c'est le même problème
pour toute la fonction publique en
général mais c'est particulièrement
criant pour l'école parce que ils sont
en première ligne parce qu'ils sont
censés former les citoyens de demain et
ça a été rappelé par le président macron
de dire que oui c'est une bataille de la
connaissance contre l'obscurantisme et
pour ça il faut mettre les moyens et je
crois que si immédiatement il faut faire
des choses c'est recruter ses formes est
bien entendu et c'est avoir des gestes
forts vis-à-vis des professeurs que
enfin on inverse la vapeur et que toute
la hiérarchie soutiennent les
professeurs quand ils sont attaqués
quand ils sont menacés
quand ils sont les premiers à dire
rappelez-vous pas de vagues c'est
incroyable on leur disait de se taire de
ne pas dire qu'il y avait des problèmes
voilà la réalité des rectorats chacun
couvre ses arrières au niveau
hiérarchique pour être sûr qu'il ne sera
pas celui qui prendra le boulet résultat
c'est un professeur qui se fait
décapiter parce qu'il a été laissé seul
par l'éducation nationale et par le
ministère de l'intérieur
donc ça suffit donc oui les beaux
discours je crois qu on en a entendu
suffisamment maintenant il est temps de
passer aux actes et de voir si les
rectorats peuvent changer et si on peut
recruter massivement des professeurs et
les réévaluer pour que les salaires
soient enfin à la hauteur et que les
classes ne soient plus des classes de 30
qu'on ait des classes où le débat soit
possible parce que quand vous avez
trente élèves vous faites ce que vous
pouvez pour gérer un joyeux bordel où
vous avez à la fois de l'obscurantisme
du conspirationnisme de la haine du prof
de enfin tout et n'importe quoi sauf
vraiment éduqués et je crois que les
mesures qu'ils avaient sur les zones
d'éducation prioritaire l on est
renforcée elles doivent être multipliés
il faut voir aussi peut-être à étendre
ces zones prioritaires ou bien à arrêter
ces zones prioritaires à faire que toute
l'école devienne une zone prioritaire
pour que c'est de voir cette bataille de
la connaissance soit gagné sans ça je
crois qu'on n'aura pas les armes pour
pour mener cette bataille
j'en tire columbia je m'adresse aux
policiers quand vous entendez emmanuel
macron dire il faut protéger nos
professeurs aujourd'hui au delà
effectivement des patrouilles des ronds
ou ou des postures statiques de
policiers devant les écoles est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il existe un lien entre
les services de police les écoles les
chefs d'établissements le rectorat
comment ça se passait ce qu'il y aurait
quelque chose à améliorer dans ce sens
là pour répondre à la première question
est ce qu'il y a des liens oui bien sûr
qui dit à délire il ya toujours eu des
correspondances colère mais pour tout
autre chose quoi alors là vous évoqué la
possibilité de protéger les profs en
interne scolaire et à l'extérieur
arrêtons de rêver c'est totalement
impossible on n'a ni des effectifs ni
l'organisation pour ça donc c'est sert à
rien d'évoquer ce type de scénario
complètement complètement à côté de la
plaque ce qui est navrant enfin moi je
suis désolé il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire la mois par rapport à ce discours à
ce que je viens d'entendre
particulièrement mal à l'aise je viens
de voir quelqu'un qui met un point
d'honneur à prendre la pause théâtrale à
choisir les mots on est noyé dans des
mots on est noyé dans une sémantique
émotionnelle qui est moi me dérange qui
moi me dérange parce que je suis désolé
comme ça a été dit mais ça pète est dit
que ce soir sur avre à votre antenne
s'était dit depuis des années plus rien
ne fonctionne
il y à une offensive de masse contre le
service public dans ce pays
cela fait plus de vingt ans que le
service public est l'objet d' attaque
frontale que ce soit l'enseignement la
santé la police j'ai déjà dit mais je me
répète ça a commencé à l'ère de la
politique de la police du résultat où on
a masqué la déflation colossal du corps
des de l'institution policière
on a masqué sa part une politique du
chiffre complètement éhontée
complètement trafiqués et on a fait
croire au bon peuple de france que la
police tout à coup et est efficace
qu'elle était rentable parce que on a
jeté en pâture des chiffres et des
tableaux excel et des tableaux
statistiques et à côté de ça dans le
même temps on supprimer purement et
simplement des policiers de terrain les
fameuses îlotiers eux qui étaient dans
les secteurs qui étaient dans les
quartiers et qui jouent un rôle
fondamental
un triple rôle un triple rôle
sécuritaire parce qu'il a été il était
l'image de
de l'état et donc de son autorité un
rôle de coordination d'un lien avec la
citoyenneté donc un dialogue et enfin et
surtout elle est surtout et aussi un
rôle de renseignements que sarkozy ait
détruit des services de renseignements
de à l'époque ça tout le monde le sait
tout le monde le dit maintenant c'est
quelque chose d'acquis mais ce que
personne n'a voulu voir à l'époque et
c'est catastrophique
c'est que ces petits policiers de
quartier qui étaient les invisibles de
la république quelque part était un
maillon essentiel dans la chaîne de
renseignement et si aujourd'hui les
services de renseignement sont à la rue
sur la ramasse au niveau de la remontée
d'informations d'exploitation des
formations de terrain c'est parce qu'il
n'ya plus de policiers de quartier c'est
les gens du renseignement de
renseignement territoriales dans les
secteurs il n'avait pas de boule de
cristal s'était pas madame irma les
informations ne les avaient pas parce
qu'ils avaient vu le la lumière céleste
non c'est parce qu'ils allaient au
contact des policiers de pierre de
quartier qui leur disaient oui mais un
tel que je le connais j'ai vu grandir je
sais ce qui fait je sais qu'ils
fréquentent et c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionnait et c'est ce que plus ou
moins a voulu rétablir enfin c'est ce
que a voulu maintenir la police de
proximité avec beaucoup d'amateurisme
d'ailleurs dans bien des cas et beaucoup
d'hypocrisie encore une fois que tous il
faut le dire c'était un site est un
marché de dupes à chaque fois et on en
crème de ça donc aujourd'hui on a un
service public dans son ensemble qui est
à l'abandon qui est à l'état de ruines
qui s'effondre donc quand j'entends
aujourd'hui des discours audio vous
protégera mais de qui se moque t'on
puisque c'est justement les mêmes qui
ont mis cette situation en place et qui
travaille qui veulent substituer aux
services d'état des services privés des
polices municipales de l'enseignement
privé par la création d favorise la
multiplication des écoles privées mais
pour qui pour une classe sociale qui de
toute façon n'est pas la même que celle
des quartiers qui sont concernés donc il
ya un vrai un vrai problème quand vous
disiez tout à l'heure que la france est
en danger oui la france est non
seulement en danger elles mêmes en état
de légitime défense ne se souvient des
aspects il faut il faut un vrai réveil
républicain mais que cette classe
politique cesse ce nombrilisme effrayant
quel ou cultive à longueur d'année à
longueur de discours et comme on vient
encore de l'entente je suis désolé moi
ce discours de me rassure absolument pas
ne me satisfait pas j'ai entendu deux je
ne sais pas quelqu'un qui était dans la
théâtralité de l'émotion
pour qui pour quoi je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas pas pour moi alors si vous
là on vient d'entendre dans les mots de
jean pierre colombiès cette nécessité
finalement de créer du lien entre les
policiers de quartier on se souvient il
ya quelques années
ces gendarmes qui connaissait tout le
monde aussi dans l'est dans les zones
rurales et le renseignement montée comme
ça on entend aussi parler beaucoup
d'unité nationale dans ces moments-là
lien ce lien cette unité nationale ça
doit passer par ou aujourd'hui mais ça
passe par nous tous mais ça passe
justement par ces héros invisible du
quotidien vous savez la colonne
vertébrale de la république et les
nombreuses et l'effet de tous ces
anonymes qui essayent tant bien que mal
de faire leur travail correctement les
policiers les pompiers
les soignants et les professeurs et cela
en systématiquement été oubliée des
tableaux de chiffres systématiquement
été oubliés des politiques publiques
d'économie des politiques du chiffre
évidemment de dire qu'il fallait faire
comme ça de mes envies une mascarade en
fait depuis de nombreuses années où ce
qui devrait défendre l'état la la la la
puissance de l'état n'ont fait que le
détricoter de l'intérieur n'ont fait que
le minée de l'intérieur pour des profits
privés pour je ne sais pas quel quels
beaux yeux de l'union européenne ou bien
de financeurs et extérieur il ya un vrai
problème de d'idéologie sur la façon
dont nous avons géré la république ou du
moins dont les élus ont géré la
république parce que ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui la font tenir au
quotidien dont on ne parle jamais sauf
quand il arrive à mahler cela ils savent
très bien qu'il manque de moyens que ce
soit dans les palais de justice dans les
cours de classe dans les commissariats
et dans les hôpitaux ceux là savent très
bien où est le problème
et ceux là n'ont jamais été écoutés on
commence maintenant à les écouter
donc je me méfie des grands discours
effectivement emprunt d'emphase c'était
bien bien sûr de faire un discours ce
soir de rendre hommage à sa mère pattie
c'était important pour sa famille et
pour pour nous tous mais au delà des
discours c'est les actes qui vont
compter et les actes souvent
malheureusement depuis le début de ce
quinquennat
ils n'ont jamais suivi les discours ou
très rarement donc
reste à voir ce que va proposer une
liste de l'intérieur dans la lutte
contre les associations et les réseaux
islamistes en france
reste à voir ce que va proposer le
président de la république et le
ministère d'éducation
dans la revue ration des professeurs et
leur protection face à des parents
agressif face un métier de plus en plus
difficile parce qu'il en va de l'avenir
de notre modèle de société sans toute
cette cette fonction publique qui
fonctionne justement
eh bien ça ne pourra pas il n'y a pas
d'avenir pour la république française et
ce sera un délitement vers une société
du nombrilisme du chacun pour soi ou la
violence sera la règle commune
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
nombreux à vouloir rejeter la violence
et si une seule violence doit être
autorisée c'est celle de l'état pour
protéger la république et pour nous
protéger
kevin bossuet vous vous rejoignez les
propos entendus à l'instant par alexis
poulain bien sûr que je rejoins ses
propos aujourd'hui on ne peut plus faire
dans la demi-mesure irons nous attendons
véritablement des mesures qui soient
fermés dire à partir du moment où vous
avez une mosquée qui ne prend pas
publiquement qu'ils ne condamnent pas
pardon publiquement le meurtre de samuel
pâti cette mosquée doit être fermée à
partir du moment où vous avez une
association qui ne condamne pas
publiquement et ouvertement le meur de
samuel pâti cette association doit être
fermée on ne peut plus faire dans la
demi-mesure et moi j'en ai marre à
chaque fois de me faire traiter
d'islamophobe de me faire traiter de
raciste ou de me faire traiter d'
extrémistes à chaque fois que je dénonce
la montée de l'islam politique aussi
bien dans les banlieues aussi bien au
sein de l'école de la république qui
continuera avec ce terrorisme
intellectuel avec cette notion
d'islamophobie en fait qu'il n'existe
pas parce qu'à partir du moment où on ne
fait plus la différence entre un
musulman et on ne fait plus la
différence entre un musulman radical
ceux qui payent la note c'est
véritablement tous ces musulmans qui
veulent s'intégrer et qui veulent
réussir dans l'école de la république
moi je peux vous dire que concrètement
sur le terrain je vois des familles
musulmanes formidable je bois des petits
musulmans formidable qui ne veulent
qu'une chose réussir dans l'école de la
république est à chaque fois que la
gauche nous accuse d'islamophobie où
nous accuse de racisme dès qu'on dénonce
les dérives tous être
son de l'islam politique c'est ces
petits musulmans qui paient donc à un
moment donné il faut agir en républicain
il faut dénoncer tous qu'on soit de
droite de gauche tels que soit notre
profession quel que soit notre place
dans la société
donc on dénonce cet islam politique il
faut qu'on dénonce ces dérives parce que
c'est aujourd'hui ou jamais si nous
n'agissons pas maintenant c'est les
islamistes qui gagneront parce que ce
qui nous attend derrière c'est
excessivement grave ils sont déjà en
train de s'organiser à travers notamment
luc l'instrumentalisation de la justice
à travers notamment
l'instrumentalisation de leur ancrage au
niveau territorial et puis il faut
absolument démonte les démanteler
l'ancrage islamistes au sein des
associations de quartier au sein des
clubs de foot au sein des mosquées
ce qui fait tout c'est tous ces
islamistes qui font qu'en fait ils
détruisent l'école que l'on peut tenir
au sein de l'école de la république qui
détruisent notre discours en disant aux
célèbres notamment le contraire de ce
qu'on leur dit tous les jours dans nos
classes donc à un moment il faut être
ferme
il faut agir c'est eux ousseynou et
c'est maintenant que ça se joue
jean-pierre colombiès kevin bossuet
parlait des familles musulmanes
formidable qu'il rencontrait on sait
aussi que dans la police dans tous les
corps d'armées finalement il y à des
personnes de confession musulmane qui
travaillent et qui sont aussi formidable
c'est important de le dire également ce
soir
envie de vous dire heureusement si nous
avions une aide en majorité de musulmans
en france qui étaient dans cette
dynamique mortifère
on serait on serait très très bien
d'engager le débat serait clos on
reprendrait plus je pense à quelque
chose on oublie quand même de citer un
pont quand même important du débat qu'il
faut pas exclure
on a parlé de beaussier dharmanand part
de monsieur macron pardo plein d'hommes
politiques d'ailleurs sur darmanin et
monsieur catex castex on pourrait faire
une petite parenthèse parce
qu'aujourd'hui ces personnes politiques
qui se font les ardents défenseurs de
des outils pour défendre notre
république et si malmenée faisait partie
des cabinets et les soutiens nicolas
sarkozy qui rompt sont en haut des
structures et de service public petite
parenthèse que que j'ai ouverte et jouer
et que je referme rapidement pour en
parler d'ailleurs assez assez longuement
mais j'trouve ça je trouve ça c'est
assez symptomatique à ces merveilleux
ces pudeurs c'est grande pudeur
républicaine
ou c'est grand c'est grande ses grandes
envolées républicaine quand soi-même on
a fait partie de ceux qui a détruit et
démentent des membres et le service
public et ça monsieur castex serait bien
de s'en souvenir
ça c'est la parenthèse donc je veux
faire mais là où je veux en venir c'est
quid du ministère de la justice parce
que tout ce dont nous parlons là en ce
moment de l'éducation nationale de la
police ou de tout autre secteur tout ce
qui peut être mis en place comme
dispositif pour lutter contre
l'islamisme quand on vient de dire ne
peut fonctionner que si c'est mis en
synergie entre plusieurs ministères
ministère de l'intérieur de l'éducation
nationale et de la justice
or je serais très curieux de savoir qui
est de ne point de vue vraiment la ligne
réel de monsieur dupont moretti sur ce
point parce que quand on parle par
exemple monsieur darmanin parler
d'expulsions de 231 231 personnes
le problématiques qui sont ou incarcérés
ou qui seront à être interpellé ensuite
expulsé mais j'ai pas entendu dire
fragiles ou alors je suis j'ai loupé une
émission mais j'ai pas entendu de
commentaires de la part de monsieur
dupont moretti sur ce point parce qu'il
le sait aussi bien que les autres et
pour ceux qui ne savent pas je veux le
dire les procédures d'expulsions
d'étrangers dans ce pays en france sont
particulièrement complexes elles sont
très lourdes et ciel sont très lourdes
c'est parce qu'on a tout fait pour
qu'elle le soit on a complexifié à
outrance le schéma procédural que les
inspecteurs fait des officiers tous les
judiciaire pardon des services de police
doivent surmonter pour obtenir un
résultat mais aujourd'hui où je vais la
faire courte l'annoncent des 231 une
expulsion
j'attends de voir si sur les 230 on en a
50 qui payent qui traversent la
frontière c'est champagne mais je n'y
crois absolument pas donc là où je veux
en venir mais je pas monopoliser le
temps de parole mais c'est que tout ce
dont nous parlons ne peut fonctionner
que si autour de la table vous avez tous
les partenaires de des services et des
institutions concernées si quelqu'un
dans le temps dans dans le schéma joue
franc tireur ou ne s'associe pas à cette
dynamique il ya cette démarche c'est
perdu d'avancé
si tu jouer et quand j'entends les
discours monsieur dupont moretti qui dit
oui tout de suite qu'ils appellent au
calme qui vont nous emballons pas ne
nous laissons pas aller au courant des
motions
je dis simplement que ça porte à
l'interrogation attendons de voir mais
on est loin d'être dans l'unanimité
en ce qui concerne l'action sur le
terrain qui est importante qui était
indispensable
il est absolument inattaquable de savoir
que des professeurs sont menacés par des
gamins de 15 ans 14 ans de savoir que la
petite mila qui étaient menacés de mort
et de viol ont la charge de deux lycées
de collège parce que a contrario on n'a
pas le courage de virer ce qui la menace
de crime sur on laisse proféré des
menaces de mort
donc de crimes par des individus qui
finalement eux sont en place ne bouge
pas alors que oui pour conclure en un
mot et puis alexis poulain vous aurez le
mot de la fin
à quoi est-ce que vous serez attentif
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines avec six poulains
après cet hommage ce soir à sa malle
pâtit ce qui vient d'être dit c'est à
dire est ce que les mesures annoncées
vont effectivement avoir lieu que ce
soit la dissolution de baraka city il ya
des recours en justice pour éviter cela
la fermeture d'une mosquée faire une
fermeture sur quelle base
derrière nous sommes dans un état de
droit donc effectivement quelles vont
être les suites légales des actions
décrites et les expulsions combien
d'expulsion sur celles qui ont été
annoncées les coups de filet dans les
réseaux islamistes y en aura-t-il
d'autres
sur quelle base voilà toutes les
questions qui vont nécessiter des
réponses et puis les réponses de long
terme pour réparer les services publics
pour réparer l'éducation nationale pour
faire que les professeurs et bien soit
enfin m dans leurs classes dans leur
école et non plus soumis à des
hiérarchies indigne idem dans l'hôpital
pour que les soignants enfin les moyens
de soigner et qu' il n'est pas à gérer
la pénurie
idem dans la police pour que enfin ce
pays fasse ce qui est nécessaire pour
protéger notre mode de vie tout
simplement
grand merci à tous les trois d'avoir
suivi avec nous cet hommage à samuel
pâtit ce soir merci à eux alexis poulain
éditorialistes merci à vous kevin bosse
fait professeur d'histoire en seine
saint denis
merci à vous jean pierre colombiès porte
parole
de l'association de police de l'union
des policiers nationaux indépendants